>>> ALL RIGHT.
WELCOME BACK T"RELIABLE
SOURCES" WHERE WE HAVE SOME NEWS
ABOUT THE NEWS TO SHARE.
CNN IS AICON OF THE CABLE AND
SATELLITE AGE, BUT NOW CABLE IS
COMPETING WITH STREAMING AND
THERE ISN'T A STREAMING
SUBSCRIPTION SERVICE FOR TV NEWS
IN THE UNITED STATES.
SO IF YOU WERE CREATING A NEWS
PRODUCT FROM SCRATCH IN 2022,
HOW WOULD YOU BUILD IT?
THAT'S ONE OF THE QUESTIONS, ONE
OF THE STARTING POINTS FOR CNN
PLUS.
THIS NEW STREAMING VIDEO SERVICE
IS LAUNCHING ON TUESDAY.
IT'S A BIG DEAL IN THE MEDIA
BUSINESS BECAUSE IT'S THE
BIGGEST BET ANY COMPANY HAS MADE
IN THE NEWS STREAMING WORLD.
CNN HAS HIRED HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
AND CREATED DOZENS OF NEW SHOWS
FOR THE SERVICE.
IT'S KIND OF LIKE NETFLIX AND
HBO MAX, YOU CAN SEE IT THERE
BECAUSE YOU SIGN UP AND YOU GET
A LIVE ARRAY OF TV SHOWS AND
FILMS, BUT IT'S DIFFERENT
BECAUSE YOU ALSO GET LIVE NEWS
AND INTERACTIVE INTERVIEWS.
SO IF YOU WERE INVENTING NEWS
VIDEO IN 2022, HOW WOULD IT
LOOK?
WELL, INSTEAD OF MAKING A
MULTIHOUR LONG MORNING SHOW YOU
MIGHT HAVE A TEN MINUTE RECAP OF
THE NEWS AVAILABLE ON DEMAND
WHENEVER PEOPLE WAKE UP.
INSTEAD OF CUTTING OFF A SEGMENT
FOR A COMMERCIAL BREAK YOU WOULD
LET STORIES BE AS LONG OR SHORT
AND THEY DESERVE BECAUSE THERE
ARE NO ADS OR HARD OUTS.
YOU WOULD HAVE TIME FOR ANCHORS
TO SHARE MORE LIKE ANDERSON
COOPER HAVING TIME TO TALK ABOUT
PARENTING AND JAKE TAPPER TO
INTERVIEW AUTHORS WITHOUT THE
BREAKING NEWS INTERRUPTIONS THAT
YOU ARE USED TO ON TV.
THAT'S THE IDEA FOR CNN PLUS.
IT'S NOT GOING TO CHANGE THIS
CHANNEL AT ALL, CNN ON TV IS ONE
OF THE MOST POPULAR CHANNELS ON
ALL OF CABLE IN THE U.S. AND
IT'S WATCHED AROUND THE WORLD
AND SATELLITE.
WE WILL KEEP DOING WHAT WE DO
24/7.
DUE TO CNN'S DEALS WITH CABLE
AND SATELLITE PROVIDERS YOU WILL
STILL NEED A SUBSCRIPTION TO
CABLE TO WATCH THIS CHANNEL, YOU
ARE NOT GOING TO GET THIS FEED
ON CNN PLUS BUT CNN HAS BEEN
ADDING CONTENT IN OTHER WAYS FOR
DECADES.
THE BEST EXAMPLE IS THE HUGE
FREE AD SUPPORTED WEBSITE.
THINK OF CNN PLUS AS ADDITIVE,
AS THE LATEST EDITION WITH
EVERYTHING FROM ANTHONY
BOURDAIN'S TRAVELS TO A DAILY
VERSION OF THIS SHOW.
YOU WILL BE ABLE TO SEE ME
WEEKDAYS 11:00 A.M. EASTERN TIME
ON CNN PLUS IN ADDITION TO
SUNDAYS HERE ON CABLE.
I'VE BEEN ON THE INSIDE OF CNN
PLUS FOR ALMOST A YEAR, WE
STARTED DOING PILOTS AND ALL OF
THAT LAST SUMMER.
BUT I WILL BE HONEST, EVEN I
HAVE HAD SOME QUESTIONS ALONG
THE WAY.
WHAT IS THE BUSINESS MODEL?
WHAT'S THE VALUE PROPOSITION?
TO GET ANSWERS LET'S BRING IN
TWO CNN PLUS LEADERS, ANDREW
MORRIS AN EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT, THE COMPANY'S CHIEF
DIGITAL OFFICER AND THE HEAD OF
CNN PLUS AND ALEX McCOWN THE
GENERAL MANAGER OF CNN PLUS AND
HEAD OF PRODUCT FOR CNN.
WELCOME TO YOU BOTH.
THIS THING LAUNCHES IN A COUPLE
OF DAYS AND YOU HAVE TIME TO BE
HERE WITH ME.
IT'S READY?
IT'S READY TO GO?
>> WE ARE READY.
>> I WAS DESCRIBING THE
DIFFERENT LAYERS OF CNN PLUS.
WHAT MAKES IT DIFFERENT FROM
WHAT'S OUT THERE ALREADY?
>> SO CNN PLUS IS OUR NEW NEWS
STREAMING SERVICE THAT LEVERAGES
CNN'S TRUST AND CREDIBILITY, THE
INCREDIBLE JOURNALISTIC
EXPERTISE OF THIS ORGANIZATION,
TO BRING NEW FORMS OF STORY
TELLING TO CUSTOMERS.
SO THERE ARE THREE THINGS WE'RE
TRYING TO DO, THE FIRST IS
EFFICIENCY, WE WANT PEOPLE TO BE
ABLE TO WATCH WHAT THEY WANT TO
WATCH WHEN THEY WANT TO WATCH,
WHERE THEY WANT TO WATCH T THE
SECOND IS LIVE, WE WILL HAVE
EIGHT NEW SHOWS EVERY DAY, OF
BEST IN CLASS EXCELLENT
PROGRAMMING.
AND THE THIRD THING IS
EMPOWERMENT, WE WANT TO WITH
INTERVIEW CLUB ALLOW USERS AND
SUBSCRIBERS TO REALLY DRIVE THE
CONVERSATION AND GO DEEP ON THE
STORIES THAT REALLY MATTER TO
THEM.
>> WE CAN PUT UP ON SCREEN ONE
OF THE PROMOS THAT SHOWS
INTERVIEW CLUB.
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT YOU
CAN'T DO ON NORMAL TV BUT CAN DO
ONLINE.
IS THAT THE IDEA FOR CNN PLUS,
FIGURE OUT WHAT WE CAN DO
DIFFERENTLY WITH THE TECHNOLOGY
AVAILABLE TODAY?
>> IT'S RIGHT AT THE PART HEART
OF WHAT CNN PLUS S IT HAS TO BE
DIFFERENT, HAS TO BE
DISTINCTIVE.
THE CNN TELEVISION CHANNEL
ACTUALLY ALL FOUR OF OUR CNN
TELEVISION CHANNELS ARE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO USERS
AND CNN.COM IS AS WELL.
WITH CNN PLUS HAVING LIVE
PROGRAMMING AND A MASSIVE ON
DEMAND LIBRARY AND THIS
INTERACTIVE PLATFORM GIVES USERS
SOMETHING THAT DOESN'T EXIST.
IT IS TRULY UNIQUE.
>> HERE IS INTERVIEW CLUB NOW.
YOU CAN LOG IN, WRITE A QUESTION
IN THE CORNER OF THE SCREEN AND
THEN THOSE QUESTIONS WILL GET
FED TO THE HOSTS AND BE ANSWERED
BY EXPERTS.
SO YOU CAN IMAGINE SITUATIONS
WHERE DOCTORS AND OTHER MEDICAL
EXPERTS ARE ABLE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE PANDEMIC,
FOR EXAMPLE.
SO THERE'S THREE BUCKETS,
BASICALLY, LIVE, ON DEMAND AND
INTERACTIVE.
DO YOU HAVE A SENSE OF WHAT YOU
EXPECT PEOPLE ARE GOING TO WANT?
WHAT KIND OF RESEARCH THAT SHOWS
WHAT PEOPLE WANT FROM PLUS?
>> SURE.
WE'VE SPENT A LOT OF TIME AND AT
ITS HEART IS GREAT JOURNALISM,
WORLD CLASS JOURNALISM.
THAT'S IMPORTANT.
THE THREE RED AND WHITE LETTERS
OF CNN THAT HAVE DEFINED THIS
BRAND FOR 42 YEARS WILL BE AT
THE HEART OF CNN PLUS.
YOU WILL SEE A REPORTERS AROUND
THE WORLD WHETHER IN UKRAINE,
WHETHER IT'S IN WASHINGTON,
WHETHER IT'S ACROSS THE COUNTRY,
THE COMMITMENT TO NEWS IS
IMPORTANT AND WE KNOW THAT
THAT'S A HUGE DEMAND FROM
CONSUMERS.
WE ALSO KNOW ASIDE FROM JUST
BEING INFORMED THEY WANT TO BE
ENGAGED EVERY DAY.
SO AS YOU SAID THE GREAT
REPORTING FROM TONY BOURDAIN,
FROM STANLEY TUCCI, AVA
LONGORIA'S NEW SERIES, THEY WANT
TO SIT BACK AND ENGAGE IN
POWERFUL LONG FORM NONFICTION
AND ALSO WANT TO TAKE PART.
THAT'S WHY INTERVIEW CLUB IS SO
IMPORTANT.
WE'VE SEEN IT TIME AND TIME
AGAIN, PEOPLE WANT TO ENGAGE
WITH THE NEWS, WANT A DEEPER
LEVEL OF CONTEXT AND INSIGHT.
>> THE NUTS AND BOLTS OF THIS,
IT NOT BEING AVAILABLE -- NOT
PROVIDING THE CURRENT CNN
EVERYONE IS WATCHING RIGHT NOW
ON STREAMING, IS THAT SIMPLY
BECAUSE CABLE AND SATELLITE
OPERATORS HAVE DEALS FOR THE
CURRENT CNN?
>> I THINK THERE ARE TWO WAYS TO
LOOK AT IT, I WILL HIT ONE AND
ALEX CAN PROBABLY HIT THE OTHER.
LOOK, THE RELATIONSHIPS THAT WE
HAVE WITH THE CABLE PROVIDERS
ARE REALLY IMPORTANT AND ALSO
THE RELATIONSHIP WE HAVE WITH
AUDIENCES WHO ARE WATCHING CNN
RIGHT NOW ARE REALLY IMPORTANT.
SO CNN WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT
AND THAT'S WHY FOR US FROM THE
BEGINNING THE MISSION WAS TO TRY
TO COME UP WITH SOMETHING
COMPLETELY DISTINCTIVE AND
COMPLEMENTARY.
YOU WILL SEE A LOT OF INTERPLAY
BETWEEN THE LINEAR NETWORK AND
CNN PLUS BECAUSE THE AUDIENCE
AND SERVICE IS COMPLEMENTARY.
ALSO THE AUDIENCE NEEDS ARE
DIFFERENT WHEN IT COMES TO A
STREAMING PLATFORM.
>> WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> YOU MENTIONED THIS UP TOP A
LITTLE BIT, THE SHOWS WE'RE
MAKING ARE ACTUALLY MADE FOR
STREAMING SERVICE.
SO BECAUSE WE'RE NOT DOING ONE
SET LINEAR FEED, WE CAN DO A
SHOW THAT ALLOWS PEOPLE TO GET
UP TO SPEED IN THE MORNING ON
WHAT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT
STORIES ARE, IF THAT SHOULD BE
FIVE MINUTES ONE DAY, 15 MINUTES
THE NEXT DAY, WE HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
THE SHOWS AS LONG OR AS SHORT AS
THEY FEED TO BE TO FULFILL
WHATEVER THE CUSTOMER NEED IS.
GET UP TO SPEED IN THE MORNING
SHOW COULD BE FIVE MINUTES, AS I
SAID, WE CAN ALSO LET PEOPLE GO
DEEP FOR 45 MINUTES ON ASKING
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
>> I'VE BEEN ENJOYING UNLEARNING
SOME OF WHAT I'VE LEARNED TO DO
HERE ON TV, FOR EXAMPLE, YOU
DON'T SAY GOOD MORNING ON
STREAMING BECAUSE SOMEBODY MIGHT
WATCH AN HOUR LATER IN THE
AFTERNOON AND THAT, YOU KNOW,
IT'S INTERESTING TO THINK ABOUT
HOW WE'RE MAKING IT IN A
DIFFERENT WAY SO IT'S NOT JUST
MORE CNN.
WHAT ABOUT THE COMPETITIVE
MARKETPLACE, ANDREW?
FOX NEWS HAS FOX NATION WHICH IS
A LOT OF ENTERTAINMENT
PROGRAMMING ON STREAMING, NBC,
ABC, CBS ALL HAVE FREE AD
SUPPORTED STREAMING SERVICES.
WE'RE DOING SOMETHING DIFFERENT,
BUT WHY?
>> WE SEE A REALLY UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY FOR US BECAUSE OF
WHAT CNN IS.
SO LET'S START THERE.
CNN IS A BRAND THAT'S KNOWN
AROUND THE WORLD, ASIDE FROM THE
BBC THERE REALLY IS NO OTHER
GLOBAL NEWS ORGANIZATION LIKE
CNN SO WE SEE A REALLY
SUBSTANTIAL MARKET OPPORTUNITY.
SECOND, WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
SUBSCRIPTION BUSINESSES AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING, AS YOU
NOTED, WE ARE GOING TO BE THE
ONLY GLOBAL VIDEO DRIVEN NEWS
SUSS DESCRIPTION BUSINESS AND
THE REASON WHY THAT'S IMPORTANT
IS I WOULD SAY LOOK AT THE "NEW
YORK TIMES."
EVERYBODY IS SO SEEING FOR KIND
OF POINT TO ORE DREAMING
SERVICES AND REALLY WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" HAS
TRANSFORMED ITSELF FROM A
NEWSPAPER COMPANY INTO A MODERN
DIGITAL COMPANY AND THEY'VE BEEN
REWARDED BY WALL STREET FOR
THEIR REALLY FAST SUBSCRIPTION
GROWTH.
>> YEAH.
>> IF WE LOOK AT THE ASSETS CNN
HAS, GLOBAL REPORTING RESOURCES,
EXPERTISE IN VIDEO, WORLD CLASS
TALENT AND ANCHORS, WE SEE A
DIFFERENT OPPORTUNITY.
IF WE HAD THE RESOURCES AND THE
BRAND OF SOME OF OUR BROADCAST
NEWS COMPETITORS, WE PROBABLY
WOULD HAVE TAKEN A DIFFERENT
PATH, BUT FOR US WE SEE A REALLY
SUBSTANTIAL BUSINESS
OPPORTUNITY.
>> ALEX, YOU AND I BOTH WORKED
AT THE "TIMES" PREVIOUSLY.
HOW DO YOU MEASURE SUCCESS HERE?
IS IT ONLY THROUGH -- CNN PLUS?
IS IT NUMBER OF SUBSCRIPTIONS IS
THAT THE MEASUREMENT.
>> NUMBER OF SUBSCRIPTIONS, YES.
WE WANT PEOPLE TO SUBSCRIBE AND
WANT THEM TO COME BACK.
>> HOW MUCH IS IT GOING TO COST?
>> $5.99 BUT WE HAVE AN OFFER
FOR THE FIRST FOUR WEEKS SO
TUESDAY YOU CAN GET 50% OFF JUST
AVAILABLE FOR THE FIRST FOUR
WEEKS AND IT'S 50% OFF FOR LIFE.
>> SO THREE BUCKS FOR AS LONG AS
I STAY A MEMBER?
>> YES.
50% OFF FOR AS